let's maybe first start just with this
idea of the intersection of crypto and
capital markets one of the the key
pieces to that is the second people here
capital markets they think regulation
and so when we think of that regulation
uh crypto historically has been uh maybe
not so regulated or the rules haven't
been as clear
talk us through kind of how you think
about uh from like the cfo seat uh
the regulatory environment and kind of
what is clear what's not clear right now
yeah no it's a it's a really important
question um
and i think
the dynamic we've seen in crypto most of
the uh investment and media attention
has really been
on a couple areas number one you're
decentralized and semi-decentralized
protocols and platforms so that's kind
of the spectrum of cryptocurrencies and
dexes and nfts and d5 and then number
two has been centralized infrastructure
to support these decentralized protocols
right so we can talk about a coin base
there and all of these are really
important but there is a massive
opportunity to unlock efficiencies and
value if we bring this incredible
innovation that has been developed into
the crypto land into regulated
centralized assets to put them on less
centralized rails less centralized pipes
that are also consistent and aligned
with regulator objectives and the crypto
world has been this amazing and vibrant
testing ground to prove out a lot of
these new innovations that we can make
use of in conventional markets to make
things like stocks work so much better
much more efficient better for investors
uh better for the issuer so like let me
give you an example what this can look
like you start with an sec registered
stock all right and instead of that
ownership being run simply kind of book
entry uh now that stock is a digital
smart line of code that can hold
information and perform functions and be
run through applications so some of the
use cases like i'm a shareholder in nike
uh i no longer need to hold that nike
stock in a big bank or brokerage to
custody it i can custody i can put in my
metamask um the stocks on the blockchain
so we have the benefit of transparency
nike knows how long i've been a
shareholder for maybe they pay me a 10x
dividend um to reward me for my loyalty
maybe i get a streaming dividend instead
of one time a quarter uh whoever happens
to own the stock before the record date
i go to the nike website to buy you know
my my new uh lebron shoes for my son or
for me whatever uh and i get 15 off
because i plug my wallet into the
website um or instead of getting nike
loyalty points i earn nike equity and
then this part's really interesting i
can then take that stock
and i can trade it on whatever platform
gives me the best price on commissions i
can take a margin loan on that stock at
whatever regulator approved provider i
can but i can lend that stock out for
someone to sell short instead of having
to pay that money to my custodian i get
to bring in competition uh and get the
best opportunity something close to my
heart uh after uh an earnings release
right maybe i get access to the
company's cfo through a token gated um
discord and i think the additional
benefit here is like the surface area of
ownership and activity expands away from
these concentrated custodians and so
things like the amount of asymmetric
information that today benefits
institutions because they're in the
trading flow and it's through you know a
small group of of intermediaries that
hurts individual investors right but
when you expand that surface area uh
that risk that goes down and also risks
get distributed so the network becomes
more resilient you start to defuse some
of these too big to fail challenges hey
you did you like this video great we
make five of them a day and post them
here on this channel make sure you
subscribe like the video and see you
next time